earlier in the show we had al michaels
and Joe Buck and last night I had those
two gentlemen on with our final guest of
the day to take us into the weekend none
other than my friend from CBS Sports in
the voice of the NFL on CBS Jim Nance
hello again Jim hello friend it's good
to be back with you that was fun last
night a little hijinks well you know Jim
I don't need to tell you being the the
veteran sportscaster and legendary voice
that you are you know how sometimes when
you're you're hooked up via satellite or
zoom or whatever's going on in this day
and age with two or three or four people
sometimes you just don't know how the
crosstalk is going to go and then
somebody just decides to just lob in a
verbal jab in the middle of the
crosstalk and then you figure out how
the crosstalk is actually working that's
what happened last night
yeah I didn't mean to go there right off
of Joe and he was excited about the fact
that in your words this is gonna have
Tom Brady early and often yes did I
happen to notice that when I first saw
our schedule that the Brady versus
mahomes game yes Kansas City a Tampa
belong to CBS that that jump off the
page and it just it just struck me that
I might as well have some fun with it
while we're here we're all friends
anyway so I said you know Joe you do
have Tom early and often but you didn't
get the game that you really wanted the
one against mahomes we've got it but I
think he was a little bit he was a great
sport about it oh we're shocked and then
I just thought I'll double down on this
and have some being a little playful
with her our great friend mr. Michaels
and talk about what is the most watched
broadcast window of the NFL one that I
understand guidance some some legs and
people try to defend this but I guess I
guess you know my point was they are the
number one rated show in primetime
NBC Sunday Night Football
and they should be very proud of that
it's that's true that's undeniable
however as I pointed oh that's right the
Jo and I would take you to the mat to
point out that the most watched or the
highest-rated because somebody might try
to say well watch all right the most
watch but also the highest-rated
broadcast window is that doubleheader
window that CBS and Fox alternate with
during the course of the season well as
everybody pointed out that it raises all
football and broadcasting boats and as
we talked about today Al and I and Joe
and I we all agree that it was the first
flex of the season last night you had
the first flex of the football season
and pull up the link right here what
they did have some some comments about
it huh no no we had fun with it and you
know cuz I mean it was a fun
conversation just seeing all of us
together you know talking football and
so many people needed you know obviously
we can discuss about when it might
happen or if it happens etcetera it's so
forth but just to get this I know you
you you've you liken it to a Christmas
morning when you get the NFL schedule in
your hands and I and you have every
right to be talking about your
excitement in that manner and I'll just
give you the floor on what else other
than that
mahomes brady game that might have left
off the page at you yeah well I should I
should just expand your thought about
Christmas morning for me sure it's one
of my favorite I would say it's in my
top 5 sporting events of the year now if
somebody would say oh that's not a
sporting event well it is for me yeah I
mean I get a final where I'm going to be
going for four consecutive months and
I'd love to already start to kind of
play these games out mentally thinking
about where the teams might be and sure
what that atmosphere might look like so
when the schedule comes down and it's
been presented today actually rose from
your show forwarded it to me and I just
had the CBS schedule yep when we were
wrong last night I still had not had a
full grasp of what the overall and
that's all schedule looks like but I
studied it I grabbed it and I excuse me
so from a little family gathering and of
course I just couldn't wait another
minute so I came into my home office
locked the door put all of that things
aside and hooked up on my computer
screen I started going through it very
meticulously one week at a time and I
just loved the reveal and you guys did a
great job by the way - happy - the years
on that show so I know there are some
geeks out there like me who could get
into the NFL schedule and trying to
figure out you know what's the main game
that day and how all the chips fall for
us at CBS it was a very happy day it was
I think your Sunday afternoon package so
this would be a beat lumping us together
here with Fox you start out by trying to
figure out the weight of your
doubleheader weeks we get eight they get
eight doubleheaders and we both have a
doubleheader on week 17 so it's the
eight that you get handed to you by our
accounting company and the NFL that you
really want to examine first that shows
you the really the strength of your
regular season schedule yes
well our eight would definitely match up
on paper better than I think anything
we've ever had before to have kids it's
a city in Tampa you pointed that out
loud yes got my homes against Brady and
as I pointed out please watch that movie
and it's always been great we'll have
the sequel with of course Tom in a Tampa
uniform but we also have mahomes against
Brees so we got to Kansas City
dynamite doubleheader road games we also
have Kansas City at home against New
England early in the year
New England Kansas City is a sexy
matchup now we know number 12 missing
but there's been enough again recent
history with those franchises playing
for an AFC championship two years ago
and a great game at Foxborough this past
December and on and on on that will be a
particularly early in the season that
will be a great interest and then you
get these cross flexes that I know
that's lost on some people but this guy
kicked in about five years ago where the
NFL took games out of Fox's allotment if
you will yes and gave them the CBS and
they did the same thing from our package
over to Fox some AFC games this to prove
the biggest audience you can on some
major matchups so they didn't get lost
in a glut of Sunday afternoon games so
short of it is we have Philadelphia
Green Bay Ambo that's not normally our
game is euro right no it's in December
that's the first Sunday in December man
bingo
and we got we got an NFC East game with
the Giants at Dallas week five that's
huge for us you know a lot of people are
going to build for the perception of
what a matchup might be based on last
year's records I think the Giants gonna
be pretty good I really do I think that
they're gonna really surprise some
people I think they're gonna be a real
force there's another one here to jail
isn't here's another one that leaps out
at me too and uh you know the Niners at
the Patriots we were just talking about
it in the break here Jim because that's
after a bye week
it's an early on in the season if
Stidham is struggling and it sure sounds
like this is gonna be stidham's gig Jim
here comes Jimmy G stroll it's Jimmy G
strolling into the house I mean you want
to talk about and they're obviously it
makes no sense to sit here and say well
they made the wrong move because Brady
is Brady and they won more times plural
after making the decision to stick with
him as opposed to Jimmy G but that is
you want to talk about a storyline I
mean week seven the defending NFC
champion Niners coming into the Patriots
how certainly if New England struggling
with Stidham that is going to be
significant to say the least the Jimmy G
return again asked one of those games
that when he looked at all of the
opponent's schedules before the NFL
matched him up and sent them out to
their networks and distributed the games
right I never would have thought in a
million years that would be our game
that wouldn't be it normally and I was
in a fox game you travel with your
conference so with yeah with it being an
NFC team San Francisco on the road that
would not normally be our game so that
was a nice gift and like I said it's
really enough in the season it's
interesting to look at the Patriots
start to the season gonna be at home
against Miami week one there they got a
Sunday night game at Seattle come back
home against the Raiders and then they
play at Kansas City so to to win
home games I mean I I'm not saying
they're gonna win a boat they might lose
them both they wants to Miami week 17
this year but two very difficult road
games to win would you agree I mean that
see at Alette Kansas City yeah so you
know you're coming out again they could
win them you know they could lose them
both
but it's a it's it starts to the season
with a new leader under center it's
gonna be interesting what they do and
then like I said you got Jimmy key
coming in all week seven I knew all
along whether Tom was going to stay with
the wingull or not as soon as we
finished week 17 opponents matchups for
the following year and I looked at what
New England had I thought man that is
the best that is the best set of
opponents I've ever seen any one team
have that's a that's a marquee team you
knew they had games at the Chargers and
at the Rams and I knew they're going to
play again
Baltimore Kansas City and Houston as
part of the 1st place schedule but the
way all the crossovers work this year
with the NFC so that meant again Seattle
that meant and a much improved Arizona
team I'm in San Francisco at home you
just didn't know how they're going to be
dispersed but I going in that New
England was going to have like virtually
every game is a great looking matchup
this was before Tom had made the
decision to go down to Tampa Bay so yeah
we're gonna still see them a lot a lot
of people thought a you and Tony might
not be seeing now the Patriots with a
frequency that you used to but we got to
see how this plays out their opponents
this year it's a really marquee schedule
for Neely yeah they've got the the most
difficult schedule obviously that that's
a that's a maybe a mirage of a statistic
because you know from year to year
things change I mean the 49ers are a
perfect example of that at this point
last year they were coming off of
drafting second overall nobody was
really even seeing them in the Superbowl
but that's exactly what happened Jim
Nantz a few minutes left with with with
you Jim and I don't like that we all we
lean on it just as much as we do right
only yeah the opponent's difficult to
schedule difficulty because I give you
example you guys had enough last night
on the street so yeah
like Baltimore Pittsburgh and Cleveland
were three of the top four with the
easiest schedule and you know why that
is when you do the opponent's schedule
now they have to factor in Cincinnati
twice at two and fourteen not once twice
right so when you're factoring in the
wind percentage of your opponent you're
already at four and twenty eight when
you do the math just because your
matchups that include the Bengals and
that's not a slam at the Bengals but I'm
just trying to show how these numbers
I don't think Baltimore schedule is easy
at all Cleveland's going to be better we
know Pittsburgh with then healthy stays
else they're going to be better and then
Baltimore has that first play schedule
of New England and-and-and-and and
Kansas City and Houston on top of a game
against you know Philadelphia and the
rest of the NFC East now what's easy
about that it just got skewed because of
the Cincinnati double record went in
went into the equation yeah and the one
thing we talked about with Joe um the
last hour Jim and I've got about three
minutes left before the show ends here
that you know he he was kind of it
landed on him that you know you when you
said last night that you called a
hundred you've called at least a hundred
Brady games and he's probably only
called about ten and most of them were
Super Bowls that Fox has had and that
and that you know now he's got gonna be
able to call more Brady games I guess
you're gonna have the Holmes games right
and the last two MVPs are residing in
air and I know you touched upon this
last night that the youth movement at
the quarterback spot is what CBS is
going to be bringing to the fore over
the next couple years
you know the AFC is is the cool
conference now and you got with with
Patrick and Lamar and and now you know I
don't want to shortchange DeSean but Sam
Donald Josh Alan Baker may feel the kids
that you're coming in to get three the
first draft picks six traffic's jump
with to Joe and to uh and and Justin
Herbert
it's it's an exciting time for this
conference your conference really
and we're the AFC Network your
conference is as good as the quality and
the star power of your quarterbacks no
that's not safe the NFC doesn't have it
they got it they got gradient breeze
they got Russell Wilson and he got some
others we got the young guys though that
are winning the awards and one guy too
just won the Super Bowl as part of that
and Patrick my home so I'm feeling
really good about worthy as she's going
and what that means as far as matchups
and you're right we're probably going to
be seeing if thinks if Kansas City keeps
doing what it's been doing we're gonna
be seeing Patrick my Holmes with the
frequency that that we did Tom Brady but
if that means that what Lamar Jackson
and Baltimore are winning these Super
Bowls in here so you know those there is
those two and some of these others I
rattled off on the list they get things
going you know that's going to be a
heavy part of what our seasons going to
be for years to come
hey Jim I appreciate the call today on
last night so last night just I guess to
bring this all full circle should the
NFL and Howard Katz and the Commissioner
take your statement about the mahomes at
Brady game as the official CBS
preemptory that that is not to be flexed
should that will protect the game so
right there's no chance that we'll the
first we had to protect one game every
week's right
barring any injuries god forbid no
that's not that's not one were letting
go up but that was so much fun rich I
was learning together because I just
love those guys and and any hours of
friends / mentor I think the to both of
us and I've gotten to know Jo so much
better in recent years we've had a lot
of fun it's for to come together last
night sheriff's and last it was gold and
I just appreciate you putting us all
together way to do that next year during
it during the reveal show I'd love it I
love it and again Jim I just really
appreciate your friendship and you
calling in to the show as often as you
do and making yourself available and I
I'm appreciative and I appreciate it
we'll chat again ground you my friend
anytime you know that okay right back
weekend you too
you bet that's Jim Nantz taking us into
the weekend
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here